à 7000 kilomètres de la métropole
le village des anses d'arlet
certainement le plus charmant du sud de
l'île de la martinique
ce bourg de pêcheurs ouvert sur la mer
des caraïbes se compose de cinq ans
c'est-à-dire de petites baies peu
profondes qu'il s'agisse de lance du
bourg de lance du four ou encore de lens
noir toutes sont réputés pour leurs
plages magnifiques et leurs eaux
cristallines
mais c'est aussi pour sa vie de village
traditionnel préserver et animé que les
martiniquais et les touristes apprécient
particulièrement de séjourner ici c'est
au sommet du bas morne une des
nombreuses collines bordant le littoral
que j'ai rendez vous avec andré bonjour
moi c'est stéphane qui habitent aux
anses d'arlet depuis toujours c'est le
plus beau point de vue pour découvrir
les ans d'armée
c'est incroyable ce village pourquoi on
l'appelle les anses d'arlet les eaux
d'arles est simplement parce que le nom
vielles de chefs caraïbes
harley qui venus se réfugier quand les
françaises ont commencé à arriver en 135
les premiers occupants desiles c'était
des amérindiens pourquoi parce que bon
il venait d'amérique et ils vont
s'installer à la martinique vers 350
avant jésus christ ces amérindiens
l'écolo français vont le rebaptiser
caraïbes au début du xviie siècle avant
de les chasser peu à peu de leurs terres
alors juste que je propose andré sait
qu'on va aller on voir le bourg oui oui
on va parler
[Musique]
et voilà on arrive dans le village là
nous avons une autre gauche la plage et
la mer et quelques embarcations de
pêcheurs
ça s'appelle des yoles qui devrait être
inscrite au patrimoine
en fait l'activité des anses d'arlet ça
reste un village de pêcheurs oui ça
reste un village de pêcheurs parce que
nous avons l'héritage direct des
premiers habitants des amérindiens avec
à la pêche à la ligne
la pêche au filet où l'on pratique
presque quotidiennement aux up down
alors là on voit que les gens viennent
acheter le poisson directement qui
arrive à l'étal oui bonjour qu'est ce
que vous avez fait celle là on a du
barracuda la carangue inoubli disque à
vos yeux le bénisse les gros yeux
j'attendais et lors le king fish on
appelle le taser ou blancs chez nous
c'est bien cuisiner sainement j'ai pas
trop le cul des vaches à lait on va y
aller on va continuer notre vous notre
promenade
[Musique]
nous nous dirigeons actuellement dans la
rue principale où tout le long nous
avons des maisons qui sont de style
colonial avec des persiennes aux
fenêtres pour une bonne aération
d'accord donc cédé maison qui
appartenait à des au côlon puis obliquer
les crises et les descendants des colons
sont dans des colos là ce sont des
maisons après appartenu à des gens déjà
d'une certaine notoriété
mais les besoins des pêcheurs même
c'était des cases le long de la mer
comment on explique toutes ces couleurs
pourquoi ces maisons sont toutes très
coloré c'est dû à la chaleur humaine de
tout un chacun dans les îles où c'est
vraiment un village charmant le monument
à ne pas rater lors de votre visite des
anses d'arlet c'est bien entendu son
église construite face à la mer ans et
171 elle fut détruite en 1762 au cours
d'une opération militaire menée par les
britanniques qui souhaitait reprendre
l'île de la martinique aux français
pourquoi elle s'appelle saint-henri
c'est un rire il porte le nom de harry
la recherche et celui qui était le plus
riche de la commune qui a permis la
reconstruction de l'église en 1762 merci
merci
sur le célèbre pont dont je retrouve
vanessa une métropolitaine qui a quitté
son sud ouest natal pour s'installer
dans cette perle des caraïbes est ce qui
vous a le plus attiré aux anses d'arlet
les fonds marins a les fonds marins way
et moi j'ai envie de voir ça c'est
justement je vous invite à aller
rencontrer françois l'aquascope peut
très bien c'est vous le capitaine de cet
engin voilà je suis le capitaine
de ce bateau vision sous marine bah on
vous suit alors est bien aussi
[Musique]
on
25 ans vous expliquer qu'ils aient
autant de cartes et de l'eau aux anses
d'arlet en fait on s'arrête nous avons
courant au large dont qu'il y ait ou
nous a laissé et qui nettoie en quelque
sorte l'eau et donc l'eau est très clair
nous avons beaucoup de poissons qui
reste dans tous les rochers et dans les
groupes
[Musique]
c'est fascinant j'adore toutes ces
coraux éventail
regardez regardez il ya un banc de
poissons bleus
[Musique]
et
thomas
on la guêpe l'un des types aussi assez
d'europe c'est un chercheur bleus
quand vous pouvez par stéphane nous
avons ans darley beaucoup de torture à
la haine à une juste ans
avec ils ont les news
voilà les magnifiques moment tout reste
[Musique]
et donc ici elle qu'elle reste plusieurs
leur maturité sexuelle dont 4 à 18 ans
c'est fascinant de ses spectacles
[Musique]
retour maintenant sur la terre ferme
vanessa tiens à me faire découvrir l'une
des plages les plus mystérieuses des
anses d'arlet avec son sable noir riche
en minéraux d'origine volcanique l'os
noir attire aussi bien les touristes que
les pêcheurs qu'est ce qui se passe là
je vois les gens qui tient des filets
c'est la pêche à la senne et donc les
pme seule chine et c'est ça et donc il y
met un filet au large de 7 ans et
ensuite les pêcheurs les touristes et
tous les gens qui sont sur la plage est
d'attirer le filet pour récupérer quoi
sans vous avez besoin dead vous les
vampires et de campagne à combien de
mètres de filets la 350 m et là ô
combien de temps on ramène le 48 n'est
pas alors la fouille année là faut tirer
quand il faut tirer foutais rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
incroyable comme arthur
comme c'est la tradition lors de chaque
pêche à la senne les participants se
partagent les plus petits pois sont
restés coincés dans les mailles du filet
ça crée du lien social en fait c'est
génial
il est temps pour moi de rejoindre le
coeur du village
et c'est avec manuela professeur de
danse aux anses d'arlet que j'ai rendez
vous racontez moi ça danse
alors nous sommes dans la région sud de
la martinique
donc nous avons une belle haie qui nous
sont proches sont à personne le belge
bell et bell est du côté sud donc on dit
en créole bel à l'issue à l'originalité
de la dumas la lys il s'est souvent les
femmes qui chantent année quelle est
l'origine de cette danse alors l'origine
du malaise vient de l'esclavagé
voilà il faut savoir que le bellec
véhicule beaucoup de valeurs le respect
de soi le respect de l'autre la
probabilité la fraternité est ce que
vous voulez qu'on dans ce bourg
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est comme moi vous avez la chance de
visiter les anses d'arlet promenez vous
dans la rue principale du village pour
admirer ces charmantes maisons créoles
contempler la superbe église saint-henri
et partez découvrir lance noir et son
étonnant sable sont